is it
one of the last chapters in your book
called white comfort yes
you acknowledge that there is diversity
and thought no doubt uh in the black
community no doubt uh extreme and i
assume you are for that uh absolutely
okay so i mean i've heard a lot of i've
had some of them on the show uh coleman
hughes was here camille foster
um
john mcwater right professor like you
he talks about the religion of
anti-racism
he wouldn't agree with everything you're
saying he says we've never been less
racist no that doesn't mean there isn't
so racism right right but
what is your view of that view
look i think look
john mcwhorter a friend of mine very
smart guy i respect all the people you
talked about they don't represent the
masses of black people number one they
don't represent the basic belief of
black people and here's the point most
black people want more policing not less
i was about to say black people are
culturally conservative they're unlike
look i don't represent the mainstream if
you will of black thought when it comes
to things like that right as an ordained
baptist minister for 40 years i've seen
some of the stuff that goes on in these
churches now black communities say look
we want people to protect us we want
when the cop when we call the cops
though the cops not to this not to fail
to distinguish us from the criminals and
the problem is black people call the
cops more than anybody if you want to
get down to who calls the cops black
people look mama i told you i want those
biscuits buttered i'm calling the cops
on you right now so the thing is
and you ain't done it right but the
point is that we want when the cops show
up
not to direct a common ordinary
interchange between two human beings
into something lethal what do i mean so
when the cops stop sandra bland for a
traffic signal or something on her car
and it ends up she's uh in jail hung two
days later walter scott down in south
carolina he stopped because his left
turn signal was wrong and the guy ends
up shooting him so the ordinary
interactions that many white brothers
and sisters can take for granted end up
in death for black people so yeah a lot
of black people don't want the police to
be abolished but bill and and i know
that that term jim clyburn others have
said hey that's the death nail you talk
about abolition do you know in the 1850s
most white people were not in favor of
abolition of slavery so things do change
so the thing is is that are you
interested in the commercial of the
product i'm all for whatever language
gets us over i'm not i'm not a stickler
for if it's abolitionist versus
reformers i just want the fact that
police people seem to consistently and
repeatedly murder kill maim harm and
destroy black life with wanton
abandonment without being held to
account and when they do
they have a qualified immunity that
protects them but i remember doing
editorials about the police that i was
sure it was going to get me arrested
right on this show right five years ago
even and and part of the point i was
making was there's never any
repercussions they now there have been
now you go down the list and lots of
police have been put in jail tried and
found guilty for stuff so i mean you
would well a few more
it's not a big tsunami it's not a
tsunami okay it used to be none
no doubt and that's progress but malcolm
x said you can't put the knife in my
back nine inches pull it out six inches
and call that progress well there has
been acknowledgement no no i'm
acknowledging that there's been some
progress but do you know the
overwhelming majority of black people
live in fear lebron james who's a rich
guy who plays for the la laker says we
live in terror against what the police
will do to us that's a reality that i
think many white people hadn't seen
until these snuff films the pornography
of black death is repeated in the cinema
of of black existence and these films
show us that no matter what hands up get
shot hands down get shot speak to the
police in a saucy way shot don't say
anything at all get shot no matter what
we do the crime is not what we do it's
who we are and that's the reality that
we have to confront when it comes to
police brutality
you